i'm jane secker and you're listening to
episode
7 of storycast 21.
in 2021 a proposed breakaway of some of
europe's elite football clubs
threatened to widen the divide between
top teams
and those who feel increasingly removed
from the top
tier but the team that cost less than
10 000 pounds to assemble struck a blow
for the minnows and shook up the
football
establishment in 2012. this is
a football fairy tale
[Music]
james hanson striker and all you ever
dream about is playing at limbo could be
a chance hanson's in behind here
goes out into a challenge my name is tim
thornton
i work for sky sports news as a sports
reporter i don't think he played the
ball hanson went down very easily
in 2009 james was stacking shells in his
local co-op supermarket near his home
in bradford and that was a chance for
danny redmond
it was ideal to be honest he just walked
down five minutes down to work and then
get my shift done and then fall back
home
one of the players who was uh in the
bradford first team at the time lived
very close to the supermarket where
james wood and he used to wind james up
saying
if he could get the tin of beans off the
top shelf on me because he was so tall
on the right hand side doyle were
witnessing
you know i was able to do a couple of
nights a week then i was probably only
working 20 hours a week
not far off minimum wage to be honest
just a couple of years later he and the
city
were going to have the kind of roy of
the rovers experience that just doesn't
happen
anymore in football
[Music]
i grew up in bolton muds which was um
just a little little town um played for
their local team and then uh moved
houses to
idle when i was about 12 i think
living in the city and got friends
obviously when i grew up
all my friends would gravitate to
support us
yeah james he grew up just a few minutes
away from the bradford training grounds
i used to hear a lot of stories then
about james and how promising he was
he was playing for one of the leading
saturday sides ecclesial united
then he made the jump up to guys lee one
of the sides just outside the
football league before bradford in july
2009
decided to take him on trial they ended
up paying yes seven and a half thousand
up front
and i think that at the time that was
the only feedback would have paid for a
player
for a long time just been dealing with
free agents and
[Music]
[Applause]
what's interesting with bradford is that
there's a massive close connection
between the fans
and the club and that is tied into
really what happened back in
1985 with the bradford fire now these
are extraordinary scenes at valley
parade it's supposed to be a day of
celebration
it was the day that bradford was
celebrating winning the title
the game has obviously had to stop
i saw the smoke about a minute ago 56
people
died that day it started as a
small fire in one under the stand but
literally within seconds within a minute
the fire had engulfed the whole stand
and the memories
will never go away from all those people
who were involved that day but a day of
triumph could turn into a dead
disaster here for bradford yeah there
was a deep rooted connection between the
fans and the club going back to the fire
and bradford later got into the premier
league and
you know there'd been a lot of
celebration a lot of hype around that
but once they dropped out of the premier
league it had been a slide
down the divisions from the premier
league to the championship to league one
and quickly into league two
we need more more money more employment
uh more
excitement uh into the north in terms of
i think there's definitely a north-south
divide in
terms of you know bradford very much a
working class
city if we could get more of the
quantity of the south into the north
i think we'd both be better for it carl
smith
i've been a breathless city supporter
for nearly 30 years
the club had been in decline for years
since kind of the premier league days
and it had been
kind of supporting them through thin and
thinner so
you know the club was in the doldrums
and and the city probably
to a certain extent as well
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
phil parkinson had taken over by 2012
and suddenly he got bradford moving back
up the tables again
[Music]
[Applause]
you know bear in mind where the club had
been we was staring
relegation out of the football league in
the face until he come in and he turned
the club around
so the home team first dwight york
quarterfinals capital one cup number
four
well the league cup and the fa cup are
the two competitions where
teams like bradford in the lower
echelons of the football league and
can draw one of the big premier league
teams so
bradford hadn't had any success in the
cup competitions
they've drawn knotts county and then
watford who were playing in the
championship
at the time then it was wigan a premier
league team and
and it's such an unbelievable feeling to
be just playing against premier league
players
and one on penalties and the feeling
after that was just unbelievable
and suddenly the fans were invested in
this cup journey
number three this is the last tie number
three is bradford city
from league two number one
and number one is alan's own club
arsenal bradford against arsenal
and then arsenal get pulled out of the
hat in the next round and
the tie was set for december the 11th
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i remember i was walking up to the
ground it was a really cold night and
i
[Applause]
announcing the arsenal team and i saw
the likes of the marlin cazzola ramsey
wiltshire uh podolski in deciding i
thought oh blimey
he's really going for this one and he's
taking it very seriously
[Music]
we was like thinking you know surely
they ain't going to play all these but
there was no other kids there and then
when the team she come in
it was literally international after
international
[Music]
arsenal one of the biggest clubs in
english football
at the time one of the biggest clubs in
europe in football uh
you need always to keep your composure
and as well when you have the chances
take them what will be the biggest list
they had a charismatic manager in arsene
wenger
and lots of superstar players as well
looking at the team that night it was
definitely close to 50
60 million in that team a lot of these
bradford players
had faced rejection elsewhere some were
coming towards the end of their career
they weren't paying fees for players
james was a rarity that bradford
paid a fee for him i think he was around
seven and a half thousand pounds and a
a bag of balls i think they paid geisley
for james hansen
the manager and the assistant who said
look enjoy yourselves this is a full
house at bradford
you've done ever so well to get here and
this is sort of your reward to play in
front of
25 000 that are going to be backing you
all night
the kick taken up field it's won well by
mccue
so i was there on the night commentating
for local radio
any chance and he's over the bar thomas
bradford had weathered a bit of a storm
very very early on in the first few
minutes but they come out the other side
of that we dug in and then we got
we played to our streams where any
chance we got we
we've put bodies in the box and i you
know met them
asked a few questions with them and
they'd not got up the pitch too often in
the first sort of ten minutes of the
game
and then i think it was nikki wells who
got brought down for a free kick
15 minutes played nil at valley parade
on paul sport
gary jones on the free kick i can
remember it now i think
um the ball's coming in and it was a
free kick that gary jones
whipped in it was flicked on at the near
post and it's a chance isn't it
feeling of disbelief around the ground
that bradford had taken the lead
city and once
they got through to half time everybody
was looking at each other
in disbelief and it was almost as if
second half normal service will be
resumed and
as it materialized bradford dug in again
in the second half
all the ball they had that didn't really
create too much and
you know dara save it was quite
comfortable in the game once we scored
the goal and
and with every minute you're looking at
the the clock
all the time thinking they're getting
closer they're getting closer
because all the hicks it and beats it
away and it goes back out to the far
side
up until like the 78th minute i think
that was the first shot on target i
think it was something
and then as you get into the last 10
minutes you're thinking you know what we
could do this
took us all it's going to come back in
the mix again here are still plenty of
bodies in and he comes back
and they score
[Applause]
comes across and vermal and knows the
ball into the back of the net
he thought that's it bradford's chance
has gone
i'll be honest i think a lot of that
lads heads did drop
but you know thankfully we dug on in
there and
managed to take them to penalties nathan
doyle to take the first one in the
shootout he steps up and he scores
great penalty in the bottom corner
and city are ahead so bradford some of
their players held their nerve one or
two didn't allen carlos
yeah arsenal their penalties weren't
good they missed some penalties
and arsene wenger turns away in disgust
and then it came through to richie jones
can he score can he book city's place in
the semi-final of the capital one cup if
he scores city and through with his
knees
perfectly with 3-2 up at the time so if
richie jones had scored then
arsenal there was no way back for them
and arsenal
i've got a chance to get out of jail
again and he's going to be thomas from
all that he rescued them in normal time
it was uh arsenal's fifth penalty for
marlon stepped up
so the marlin had to score to keep
arsenal in the tie and
you know i just remember all the lads
ready you know hoping the keeper would
make a great sale or something
he'd almost come from the high of richie
james could win it here and bradford are
through to
he's missed and that's it chance gone
again the marlon will
will score this and arsenal will go on
and win it and he's stepped
up
[Applause]
and he hit the post and that was it it
was all over
you know we just saw the ball bounce out
and you know then we just
realized we've done it and you know we
just ran to the keeper as you do
i was saying the main stand and everyone
was uh was very much
kind of shoehorned together and the
place just erupted and i've not heard
kind of noises like that in valley
parade for
for a long time
the win over arsenal was massive but
then bradford drew aston villa in the
semi-finals
up until then it was obviously the
biggest moment of his lives and
so we're thinking like we've got half a
chance here
in towards the back
james hanson actually scored the crucial
goal at villa park to take bradford to
wembley
to beat villa after the arsenal win was
just unbelievable
achievement for a lead two club to get
to a major cup final
so obviously it was chelsea b swansea in
the other semi-final and
at the time swansea was playing probably
the best football
you know i've seen from an outside top
14. and there's the final whistle
city are winners of the capital one cup
final
by five goals to nil it's just a shame
that we couldn't
play love on him that day it was that
good
bradford city have been beaten well
beaten here today but their
achievement must never be forgotten and
never underrated
graffit were well beaten but the story
was about getting to
to a major final for a league two club
and then bradford managed to get
themselves into the playoffs and they
were back at wembley at the end of the
season in the playoffs
james hansen scored a game in the
playoff final against northampton
and it capped off a fairytale season
because not only did bradford get to the
lead cup final we also got promotion at
wembley into league one
as a fourth team at the side to go to um
wembley and play a premier league side
he's unheard of and
you know with it being a full house as
well it was absolutely brilliant
occasion for me and my family and
[Music]
for me to be living in bradford as well
it's probably made it even better for me
you know i'd be going to the shop and
you'd be getting five or six
fans talking to you about the games and
yeah it was it was a brilliant year to
be involved in
well for james he was the only player in
the in the team from
from the area the fact that he worked in
the local supermarket
the fans used to sing he used to work at
the court that was the
the champion used to echo around the
ground all the time
[Music]
he created that bond again between the
city and the football club and
it was it was just a fairy tale season
of fairy tale story
for a lead two side to achieve what
bradford did that season i don't think
it will ever
ever happen again
a football fairy tale was written and
produced by robert mulhern
for more information on this story log
on to sky news dot com forward slash
storycast 21.
next time i just saw you know the
ceiling crashing down just the
destruction
we're in belgium as brussels experiences
its
deadliest attack since world war ii
the second terrorist was going towards
the main exit
i passed him and he detonated the bomb
you